la mia botta di più grande è aver finto
un gratta e vinci da 300mila euro con
annessi 6.000 euro al mese per 20 anni
a me a sfiga essermi fidata di mia madre
mi aveva detto che ci volevano tre
simboli per vincere quella somma e
quindi io ho buttato il gratta e vinci
ne bastavano due
ciao posto dirigendo ciao ragazzi
bentornati una nuova puntata di vita ha
buttata il tema della puntata di oggi a
botte di si può dire botri colpi di
fortuna per un tema così speciale ho
pensato di invitare all'interno degli
studios di casa mia una ragazza che
diciamo è stata baciata dalla fortuna
prima che questa si rifacesse le labbra
questa ragazza sta a una gioia un po
come pamela prati st marco carta girone
e sto parlando della migliore amica di
mia cugina morgana ciao
dovete che ci conosciamo noi ci saranno
almeno 16 si oggi 16 diciamo sì a tutto
questo ragazzi è il compleanno di
borgata quindi enrico a cantare la
canzone che avevano detto che li avresti
cantato per oggi in do maggiore
signore e signori
[Applauso]
bando alle ciance su apriamo qui in
tanti auguri parliamo di batteri sono
curioso di vedere che cosa è bene e cosa
no dico io ho bevuto perché titolo
quando si brinda chi beve di un albero
non sarete portasse male ma non parta
soja c'è stato un particolare momento
della mia vita di circa un anno in cui
in qualsiasi posso andavo trovavo soldi
a terra
fatto sta che una volta entro dentro
centro commerciale appena la destra
dell'ingresso c'è un bancomat è al
momento in cui ci passo davanti a sé
come 250 euro
questa si chiama per svaligiare pure
questa si chiama rapina o attestato il
massimo ritrovato per terra
5 centesimi è mai davvero perché non ho
mai trovato soldi per terra ma perché tu
non sei una che si guarda attorno
tu non sei uno che guarda per terra se
uno che guarda il cielo quando camminano
erano un buffet micene aromatica che
aiuta chissà quanto tempo ancora note di
sei mesi ne ho persi tanti soldi lo sai
come mi perdo metti i soldi in tasca
quando tirò fuori il telefono si tirano
fuori i soldi ciao
è questo il motivo per cui li perdi sai
chi li ha trovati tutti io non ho mai
trovato niente e sono una di quelle
persone che se trova il portafoglio e mi
è capitato lo restituisce con
assolutamente tutti i soldi dentro io
l'ho aperto c'era del verde 15 maira da
marijuana
però ho preso solo la carta d'identità
giornata li ama ringraziare tutte le
lingue non avranno più impiegata ospite
nonostante la mia vita sia un apostrofo
rosa tra le parole mai una gioia sono
riuscito ad avere un colpo di fortuna il
giorno del mio primo esame
all'università ritrovo come assistente
da daniele se resta un mio amico e la
presenza dice è interrogato 30 e lode
queste realtà non è troppo fantascienza
nella nostra famiglia non possiamo dire
chi non possiamo dire cosa però
cameriere scilla c'è un bacio dei che la
metà basta ma non è derivante dal giorno
del compleanno però io per esempio porto
la mia esperienza è presente gli esami
universitari quando c'è sempre
l'assistente il più stronzo un registro
più stronzo che c'era tra i tre elio
pescava sempre quella come il drago
della ricotta facciamo uso ospite enrico
augurio vederti che ti seguo da quando
devo tipo 14 anni notte ora non è o 15
ben 26 20 avevo tipo 13 di 12 anni ma
cosa del genere rapite che era un po
bulli dato a scuola niente un ragazzo il
bullo mi stava spinto l'anno se non
fosse in quel momento un piccione stava
giusto calandomi in testa questo istinto
una brand è il mio mondo sono in africa
è pagata in testa
anche se ho ringraziato dio perché ho
capito che esista vedi che spesso gli
uccelli sono un pochino la risposta è
rimedio la sofferenza è questa qui
secondo me è una grande allegoria di
tutto questo come hanno fatto nuova
almeno due volte perché io invece mi
tosto i capelli mi dà addosso ma io devo
vedere da lì a breve un ragazzino sala
quando sei piccolo ho pianto troppo
cosa hai fatto alla fine niente che ho
fatto c'era una fontanella e mi sono
lavato i capelli però il ragazzino l'ho
visto lo stesso con metatesto asciutta
giova ora mi sento a disagio perché
secondo me puzza voti di roba di
volatile
non è andata meglio ma perché tu sei
sempre stato un cuoricino tenero chieco
ai fatti perché poi i lati anni per the
queen theodore era uno le persone ne
sono sicuro la mia più grande è
sicuramente stata quando sono riuscito a
vincere con un solo al cielo ultimo
livello di android altre botte ti
ringraziamo per questa grande
insegnamento nostro messi sa qual è
stata la tua botta di più grande riesce
a ricordino diciamo nel grigio di questo
passaggio un momento in cui tu hai detto
la vita forse la pena cela cielo e sono
stata contentissima allora avevo finito
la dieta la prima cosa che ho fatto è
prendermi una kinder delice alle
macchinette e linee sono cadute due per
le ho mangiate entrambe le
forse ho anche pianto la mia essere me
ciao pure c'è un ospite presi al bar una
bustina di patatine in quel periodo
c'erano le sorpresine di cars
nella collezione c'erano sette
personaggi dei film nella stessa bustina
di patatine ho trovato 9 sorprese tutti
e sette i modelli più due doppioni
io sto immaginando come può accadere
questa cosa cioè nel senso non è che c'è
uno che ha già dovuto presentarlo sotto
al distributore lo so io si è fermato il
nastro mentre l'ato nastro sopra
scorreva e quindi è quello che ti fanno
vedere come nel mondo fatte le cose che
ne so tipo questo bicchiere ti fanno
entrare in fabbrica e ti fanno vedere
tutto quello che succede
lo sapevo tipo come è fatto questa volta
che cerca di fare questa audio sono
sempre stato la persona abbastanza
fortunata ad esempio l'anno scorso per
puro caso ho trovato un concorso e
consisteva nel inviare il sexy più
brutto poter inviare e il sesso il
frutto a livello nazionale avrebbe vinto
il telefono e io l'ho visto cioè sono
così fortunata o sono così brutta non ho
anche un portafortuna un giorno per
sbaglio stampato troppo e fototessere
iniziate a distribuirle ai miei amici
ovviamente che cosa devo fare ogni volta
che la distribuito una politico al
nemico giorno dopo mi scriveva che aveva
preso un bel voto a scuola e quindi
tutto è iniziato a chiedere mia fortuna
di judo riposarvi quanto fortuna
evidentemente questa cosa carina e sono
felice pensa se stampi la foto del set
di brutto e la distribuisci padre pio vi
serve il contatto
no non credo sia così fortunata ragazza
di cui non diremo il nome per motivi di
privacy contatta morgana ti lasciamo qua
sotto il suo link anche per farle gli
auguri di buon compleanno anche se
uscirà in ritardo insomma ma giusto per
farti vedere che nel mondo in un posto
buono che le persone che ti vogliono
bene
mandaci una tua foto ci sono quelle
persone positive me è successo solo con
un vecchietto che portava fortuna
realmente cioè ogni volta che lo
incontravo era del quartiere mi
succedeva
non un disastro come una giornata
normale mb grazie grazie per tutte le
giornate canoniche per mi ha regalato
beh ovviamente la botta di chi non è
capitato a me però capitato a mio
fratello si è presentato ad un esame
all'università e ha preso 29 ma
mancavano di com'è possibile
quindi c'è qualcuno che non ha preso 29
la maggior parte delle botte coincidono
comunque con un colpo di sfiga
dell'altra persona sarebbe mai pensato
cioè si trovi 50 lo per terra qualcuno
se li è persi sono una grandissima fan
dei videogiochi
il concerto con l'orchestra sinfonica
faceva tappa milano
io andai a quella di milano e poi potevo
tornare a quella di roma però insomma
non mi sembrava il caso di spiegato
altri soldi allora la nintendo fece un
concorso dove poter rivincere dei
biglietti per il concerto della data di
roma mi arriva l'email che avevo vinto
due biglietti non è finita qui alla data
di milano ero andata con quello che al
tempo era il mio ragazzo ovviamente mi
sarebbe piaciuto tornare con lui anche a
quella di roma
però comunque anche mio fratello e mia
sorella essendo fan della saga volevano
venire e quindi mi trovavo nella
posizione in cui avevo un biglietto per
me è un biglietto di un'altra persona
che non sapevo che tocchi dare quando mi
sono arrivati i biglietti anziché
arrivarne una sola politica mi sono
arrivati due io ho vinto 4 biglietti
il concetto fu bellissimo l'abbiamo
vista tutti e quattro insieme e lo vuoi
capita mi farò sapere
incomincia prova adesso mi capita un
qualcosa di bello adesso mi capita
qualche rèpaci però pensa tipo una cosa
bella pizza pasta per pizza pizza pizza
ha sempre sognato di incontrare steven
tyler degli aerosmith nella mia vita
siamo ha detto e non pensare positivo
allora se qualcuno sente questo appello
di questa ragazza qualcuno ai piani alti
qualcuno che vuole dare per ricevere
dalla vita perché sapete l'ho sempre per
poter avere bisogna prima fare
mettetevi una mano sul cuore questa
ragazza guardatela è distrutta sul viale
del tramonto
una ragazza che non ha più nulla
guardatela direste che il suo compleanno
oggi niente c'è niente da ridere se non
fosse per il decadimento dei suoi
tessuti no
se siete da fuori e conoscete steven
tyler avete la possibilità di realizzare
un sogno un sogno avere un sogno
lavoravo in un tabacchino è un signore
aveva mai mi disse allora gioca questi
tre numeri sbagliati a cliccare pulsanti
e giocai tre numeri a caso questo
cominciò ad adire alle peggiori cose
contro di me finchè comincia la partita
del famoso 10elotto si scopre che il
tizio di 300 euro con i numeri casuali
che io avevo giocato insomma inutile
dire che ha chiesto scusa 3000 volt a un
volo per tutte le cattiverie che me
l'hai detto ma opportunista vuoi
chiedere scusa di mezzo alla vittoria ma
ieri dai tutti perché in realtà la 20
lei
ciao a tutti sono andata a casa troviamo
per terra 50 euro
siamo dati sono in giro per l'elezione
di qualcuno che messaggio mi dai alla
fine di questo vino ai capitoli romano
sono brucia ciaia
avevo capito alto per noi ragazzi siamo
rete alla fine di questa puntata vi
ringrazio con tutto il cuore morgana per
essere venuta il giorno del suo
compleanno
insomma all'interno degli studios the
casa mia diciamo che ringrazio per
questo progetto
ringrazio voi per averci seguito fatemi
sapere fateci sapere qual è stata la
botta di più grande il colpo di fortuna
più grande che vi sia mai capitato culo
non si può dire è arrivata
mia cugina fatemi sapere questa guardare
se lo avete già fatto iscrivetevi a
questo canale attirate la campanella
delle notifiche per non perdervi nessun
video e ci vediamo la prossima settimana
con un'altra puntata sempre alle 14 ciao
ciao